- La quatrième tentative aura
été la bonne, Moscou a
finalement ouvert un corridor
humanitaire à Soumydadans
le nord-est de l'Ukraine,
une première depuis le début
de l'invasion.
Environ 5000 personnes, dont
1700 étudiants étrangers sont
partis en convoi. Le cessez-le-
feu temporaire a essentiellement
été respecté.
Les évacués ont pu constater
les dégâts, mais aussi
la férocité des combats près
de la ville assiégée en voyant
les carcasses des chars d'assaut
russe.
Butin de guerre, des soldats
ukrainiens ont mis la main sur
des caisses de munitions
abandonnées.
La crise humanitaire prend
de l'ampleur chaque jour, plus
de deux millions d'Ukrainiens
ont fui leur pays en 12 jours.
- Lviv, centre névralgique
- Lviv, centre névralg
de l'ouest du pays, est dépassé.
200 000 réfugiés y vivent
temporairement, 50 000 autres
y transitent chaque jour.
Une partie du bâtiment
intérieur du stade de football
de Lviv a été transforméeenenene
tournante pour des milliers
de réfugiés qui passent ici,
pour ensuite rejoindre
d'autres pays.
Sacha n'a quitté son domicile
que pour protéger sa fille
de 4 ans, Lisa, déjà capable
d'identifier le calibre
des différentes munitions,
à son âge.
Elle ne remerciera jamais assez
bobobobons samaritains.
Au stade de football,
leésésésésés sont logés, nourris
et habillés temporairement,
le temps de trouver un endroit
où vivre, plus souvent
qu'autrement à l'étranger.
Daniel, lui, est prêt à
enavavavavavantage, ça lui fend
le coeur de voir tant de jeunes
enfants évacués.
Des réfugiés arrivent
à l'église Jean-Paul II de Lviv.
Ils pourront y rester aussi
longtemps qu'ils le désireront.
Dans sa chambre qu'elle partage
avec six autres membres
de sa famille, Anya veille sur
son Makar qui n'a que 2 mois.
Elle espère pouvoir trouver
son mari bientôt. Même si elle
est épuisée, elle essaie
de garder espoir.
Pour ce flot incessant
de réfugiés ukrainiens,
c'est i i i i i i leur reste :
l'espoir. Aussi minime soit-il
par moments.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Lviv, en Ukraine.